hey everyone I'm Abbi sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen a lot of people ask me
how I managed to get everything done on
the day I like to think it's cuz I'm a
woman obviously but it also has a lot to
do with caffeine I do love myself a good
cup of coffee or tea but there are
definitely more helpful ways to get in
your fix than others case in point the
Frappuccino full fat milk sickly-sweet
syrups candy bits and mountains of
whipped cream make these calorie bombs
more of a decadent dessert than a
refreshing summer drink oh but still
some reason I see the frothy coffee and
the mountains of pillowy whipped cream
Oh 20 teaspoons of sugar later I don't
feel so well
some of these frozen treats clock in at
almost 600 calories and 3 times their
suggested amount of added sugars before
you've even had breakfast that's not a
drink that's an 8 a.m. dessert for a
family of four it's not worth it guys go
get a slice of cheesecake and call it a
day so that's why I've developed three
dairy-free suavo chinos without with any
artificial sweeteners or flavors and a
fraction of the calories fat sugar at
your favorite frozen drinks first up my
salted caramel mocha swap a Chino to
start I'm gonna make a big batch of
vegan whipped cream into this can of
coconut milk I pop sit in the freezer
just to separate the solids that I whip
until thick and creamy with a teaspoon
of vanilla next I'm gonna make this
vegan caramel out of coconut sugar and
coconut milk well it's still a sugar
coconut sugar has a lower glycemic index
than regular white or brown sugar so it
won't spike your blood sugar as much
when consumed in small amounts I
combined a quarter cup of coconut sugar
with one tablespoon of water and two
teaspoons of lemon juice in a medium
saucepan and bring it to a boil once
bubbling I immediately add in 1/2 a cup
of light coconut milk 1/4 teaspoon of
sea salt and a half a teaspoon of
vanilla I then simmer it for about 15
minutes until the liquid becomes thick
and dark and I remove it from the heat
and set it aside
and finally let's blend two cups of
almond fresh unsweetened vanilla almond
milk 2 teaspoons of unsweetened cocoa
powder 2 frozen ripe bananas 1 cup of
cold pressed coffee 3 cups of ice and
about 6 teaspoons of the salted caramel
then pour it into four cups top it off
with a dollop of coconut cream a drizzle
of caramel and a sprinkle of fleur de
sel in all of my recipes today I'm using
almond fresh unsweetened vanilla almond
milk not only is a dairy and lactose
free but each cup gives you 30 percent
of your daily needs for calcium almost
half of your requirement for vitamin D
and only 35 sugar-free calories that's
just over a third of the calories of
skim milk hello the cleaning season next
up my green tea creme you know for the
coffee averse in a large blender I add
two and a half cups of almond fresh
unsweetened vanilla almond milk two and
a half teaspoons of matcha tea powder
one teaspoon of vanilla extract two and
a half ripe frozen bananas one
tablespoon of honey and three cups of
ice divide it between four cups top it
off with a little more of that coconut
cream we made and sprinkle it with a bit
more matcha tea powder and finally my
decadent tasting red velvet yeah I'm
hopping right on board with that new
dessert like Frappuccino menu proving
you can have your cake and drink it too
let's blend one and a half cups of
almond fresh unsweetened vanilla almond
milk half a cup of cold pressed coffee
one and a quarter cups of frozen
raspberries too ripe frozen bananas four
teaspoons of cocoa powder four teaspoons
of honey and three cups of ice divide it
between four glasses top with our
coconut cream a teaspoon of dark
shavings in a tablespoon of freeze dried
raspberries so there you have it folks
three all-natural dairy free frozen
coffee hacks that will save you doodles
of calories fat and sugar mmm can't do
anything about the brain freeze but just
sip and savor slowly and you should be
okay thanks so much for watching guys
for great guilt-free snacking and
sipping ideas be sure to subscribe to my
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen today we're gonna be
talking about antioxidants we hear the
word all the time we know we should be
getting more of them but why are they
even important anyway
you